foreign
[Music]
Finland are connected in many ways just
in terms of cross-border travel millions
of people make the journey between
Helsinki and Tallinn every year but the
two EU Nations ties go much deeper than
that now both estonians and Finns can
pick up their prescribed medicine from a
pharmacy irrespective of which country
they are in that's been made possible
thanks to any prescription and
e-dispensation service set up in 2019
the process is fast and simple
foreign
's electronic identity card the
pharmacist uses the e-prescription
platform to check and then hand over the
prescription
[Music]
once we are in the system we see the
list of the prescriptions made for this
person and the system automatically
translates it to Estonian a language so
everything is understandable for us
after the prescription is assault it
takes some minutes for our system to
send the information to the homeland of
our patient and then the prescription is
either deleted or the amount of the
prescribed medicine is decreased
foreign
to buy almost all prescription medicines
except psychotropic narcotic medicines
and extemporaneous medicines which are
prepared in the pharmacy
Estonia is a prescription system was led
by the country's public I.T agency its
experience is being used as a case study
for the European health data space
recently launched by the European
commission this major project aims to
dramatically improve cross-border
Healthcare by harnessing patient data
the e-prescription system relies on the
European e-health digital service
infrastructure the network provides
continuity of care for people traveling
across Europe
two cross-border health services are
currently being introduced in
prescription and e-dispensation it
includes a summary of a patient's
medical history
as countries to start using the
e-prescription in e-dispensation system
are Estonia Finland Croatia and Portugal
although European countries will
gradually join the system over the next
few years
foreign
Package Mobile package with my phone it
should be as simple with cross-border
ehealth services that actually I don't
have to think that do I have the
prescription on the paper with me it
shouldn't be necessary I just should
walk in to the pharmacy show my ID and
get the medicine I want
connecting different Healthcare
Providers across Europe requires a high
level of security and interoperability
[Music]
we need to identify people securely and
in Estonian case we have two ways how to
do that there is a ID card and the
mobile ID in the devices like in the ID
card there is a chip which contains your
private key which identifies you to the
system
in the future cross-border health
services in Europe should be similar to
mobile phone roaming patients medical
data and prescriptions will follow them
when they are abroad guaranteeing better
care and treatment
[Music]
foreign
[Music]